hey guys now some of you asked me to
make a video about traveling tips I
traveled a lot for many years as an
international model and I learned so
many things to make traveling a lot
easier and more convenient so in this
video I'm gonna share 25 tips with you
from leaving the house I mean booking
the flight up until arriving at your
destination and if you watch the video
all the way to the end I'll give you a
bonus tip as well let's not waste any
more time let's get to it
foreign
double check your passport early
you know a lot of people book flights
and then they prepare everything but the
one thing they need their passport
is not okay it has expired so check
early and then when you do go always
keep it with you in a certain spot that
you you know it's always there on your
body or in your back because that way
you will never lose it
book a flight early
you never just want to book a flight
just before you go because then we'll be
more expensive so the earlier you book
it the cheaper it is so when you look
online try not to travel in a high peak
season and don't just take the airline
you like look on websites like sky
scanner to see better deals
and then look out for package deals
holiday destinations certain places or
hotels or companies let you book a
package deal where they include your
accommodation your flights and a few
other things and then when you work it
out it can actually be a lot cheaper
than compared to where you would just go
and book the flight by yourself
cookies
no not the cookies you eat the cookies
on your computer clear your cookies and
not just that
just delete your search history
or if you don't want to do that then
just use someone else's computer because
here's the thing we live in a world
where companies just want to make money
so once you start looking into flights
you are flagged by them they know you
are interested so you see a price you
log out you go to your wife and you tell
them hey this is the price maybe we
should book it and then you decide on it
and yeah okay let's do it and then you
go back and then somehow the price is
more expensive
yes because they know that you're
interested in it and then when you go
they just raise the price
join an airline as soon as possible
or the group that they are with so
sometimes they have these groups where
there are a lot of airlines that are
affiliated so Join one because
the more you fly the more points or
miles Air Miles you earn and then you
get stuff for free of course it depends
on the tier that you are on for example
Qatar has burgundy silver gold and then
Platinum
now the worst thing when it comes to
traveling is waiting I mean you wait for
everything but now if you are a silver
member or up then you can board early
with the business loss through my points
I got three access to the lounge which
means you get free food comfy seats or
even a sleep area you can also take a
shower and a place to charge your
electronics now this is huge especially
for those flights with those long
layovers because then you just get stuff
for free and you can also use your miles
to get cheaper flights or upgrade your
seat check it out for yourself
get travel insurance not a lot of people
think about this and you know anything
can happen at any time so when
unforeseen things happen they are in
trouble and in debt if they don't have
travel insurance
check in online as soon as you can
some Airlines they open 24 hours others
48 hours before the flight so then you
gotta go and check in as soon as
possible because then you can choose the
best seats before other people do now
you know when you go to the airport and
you go in and you have to go stand those
queues to get your tickets most of the
airports have a queue specifically for
people who have already checked in
online so then we'll save some time as
well oh and uh when you do choose your
seats
well it depends on who you are and what
you prefer but try never to sit too
close to the toilet because it will
always be noisy also never sit in the
middle
because you'll have someone on the left
someone on the right and you don't have
you will never have a lot of space it is
oh especially long flights that is the
worst if you like nice views just sit to
the window see you know but the only
negative thing there is you need to
stand up if you need to go to the toilet
and you need to kind of squeeze past the
other passengers but if you like to
stand up a lot then just sit on the side
where there's no one to the right you
know on the aisle the only problem there
is when people walk past you they
usually bump you they don't Focus for
some reason
and then one last thing when it comes to
choosing your seat if you don't like
kids or other people pressing the screen
and share behind you all the time at
your back I mean that's been
ugh the worst for me so then you just
need to sit all the way to the back of
the plane
choose your meal options before the
flight ahead of time you can go online
and just select the meals that you would
prefer and then they can prepare it for
you ahead of time you can get vegetarian
gluten-free dairy-free religious diets
or even no lactose
get the best suitcases
you know a lot of people when they fly
they think man I'll just buy a cheap one
the problem is it will break so then you
will need to take out money again and
pay for another suitcase so at the end
this is going to cost you a lot more you
can get good quality bags from remoa
Samsonite way travel and paravel oh and
I'll add all the stuff I'm talking about
in this video for you in a video
description down below so it's just a
bit easier for you to go and check out
wear your bag before you fly I've seen a
lot of people in those queues you know
when they get to the counter and they
are notified hey your bag is too heavy
and then they need to pay a lot more
money or take out some stuff you don't
want that to happen to you so weigh your
back oh and always remember this they
allow you to take a five kilogram bag
with you the carry-on you know on the
plane that you don't need to check in
but a lot of people think okay they want
to take a laptop back for the laptop but
that means that's already five kilos so
now I contact another bag
I've been flying a lot and I always take
another bag as well so don't worry about
it your laptop that's one thing
take another bag as well to put all your
stuff in
go early
the earlier you go to the airport
the less stress you will experience
because when you need to go and get your
ticket and drop off your bags there will
be less people not only that when you go
through the area where they need to
check your bags then that'll be stress
free because you know you have a lot of
time and you can be on the plane in time
so get your ticket go through the back
check area and just go and sit down and
have a coffee and relax oh the other
reason why you want to be smart about
when you go to the airport is you never
want to go to the airport in rush hour
so remember this when you book your
flights as well
be friendly and just ask around if you
don't fly a lot if you're a little bit
stressing and you're like oh where
should I go don't stress Don't worry
just look around and ask a few people be
friendly people like
there are also these information kiosks
where the people
actually have to tell you where to go
and help you that's their job so just go
and ask them
keep all the scannable objects keep it
separate keep all the stuff you know
those separate scannable objects that
you have keep it separate because when
you go through those back checks there
are things that they will ask you to
take out of your bags and scan
separately and that's just going to take
a lot more time and you know people are
strange for some reason
it always surprises me how rude people
are just normal people that's flying
who's behind you wants to push and wants
to get their stuff and they're stressed
and
so when you go there you want to be
prepared so keep your laptop your iPad
your power bank liquids or any other
electronics together in one place just
so it's easier to scan
ask for a better seat you know most of
the time
airlines are not fully booked that means
there are open seats so all you got to
do is just ask for a better seat
also when you fly in off peak periods
you know when it's not that busy
there might be only 30 40 50 percent of
people in the plane that means there are
a lot of seats open
there were a lot of flights that I went
on where I could just sleep on three
seats you know that's just an amazing
flight especially if you have to fly
very far
take your phone charger with you on the
plane you know most airplanes these days
they already have those areas on the
seat where you can just charge your
phone and you don't want to travel while
your battery is dead I mean that you can
just create a lot of problems for you
also always take a power bank
take your own headphones with an adapter
this is important especially for those
long flights I mean you know you get
these free headphones but they are
really bad quality I mean most of the
time Airlines have great entertainment
movies and TV series to watch while you
fly but it comes with low quality
headphones people around you are noisy
so you want good headphones that just
cancels out the noise all you need is
this guy
this adapter plug will let you use your
own headphones you can also get this
Bluetooth transmitter which is amazing
because you don't need to struggle with
the wire especially when they bring you
food the wire can be in your way
ask for Stuff
you know most of the time people just
sit and wait you know they think they
can't ask for anything so they have to
wait for the food and snacks or drinks
no there's a a button on your chair that
you can press right a light goes on and
then a flight attendant she or he knows
that hey someone needs something so you
they they come and you just ask them hey
can I get a water or can I get some
snacks or can I get this or that and
they will bring it to you
foreign
don't just eat anything that you feel
like you want to eat
or even drink for that matter why
because you might have a very bad
experience a very uncomfortable flight
and it's going to influence your jet lag
as well don't want to feel bloated have
headaches or Worse diarrhea
let me tell you that toilet on the plane
is not a toilet that you want to go to a
lot it's not always that clean it just
feels work
and here's the thing when it's occupied
it's occupied you can't go in so you'll
be in trouble
so to prevent this drink a lot of Still
Water avoid carbonated drinks and
alcohol and eat less especially carbs
which your body will struggle with more
to digest wild travel in short just
drink a lot more water Still Water eat
veggies and dried fruits instead of all
the unhealthy bad stuff carbs
take sleeping pills and earplugs
people on a plane are noisy most of the
time there are a lot of people who just
don't care they're not considerate of
other people
uh that's the worst part of flying for
me so you will need to get some rest
especially if you want to arrive at your
location feeling fresh all you got to do
is take a few sleeping pills with you to
knock you out and good earplugs to block
out all the noise
check the local time this is important
especially if you have an overlay
you are in a different country with a
different time so you just check your
watch and think oh why do I have so much
time left I'm gonna spend a lot of time
here what am I gonna do and then you
don't realize your flight might actually
be just in a few hours because the time
is different a good tip to remember is
don't look at your watch just look at
your phone because While most
smartphones these days it will adjust
the time difference automatically
take stuff to keep you busy take stuff
with you or download it on your iPad or
phone to keep you busy because you know
most airports they have terrible Wi-Fi
some don't even have Wi-Fi at all well
unless you go into the lounge but you
don't want to be bored for hours so just
bring a good book download a few
episodes on Netflix or just bring your
work with you
pay for the lounge if you have a long
overlay you know sometimes people get
overlays of 5 to 12 hours even more and
that's just hectic I mean you you need
to pay for food every time you're gonna
eat but if you work it out the lounge
might actually cost you cheaper and for
all that amount of hours you can have
free food free drinks free shower nice
areas to rest
I mean come on it's a no-brainer you get
all the perks
when you land get through immigration as
soon as possible and to all those people
where you know they just stand up you
know the flight hasn't even landed you
they just stand up over a headlock or
get their bags you know they bump people
it's
no that's stupid and it's very annoying
to a lot of people if you've been flying
for a long time you know you can be calm
and just rest until the plane comes to a
stop then get your bags and then when
you're out of the plane move as fast as
you can to the immigration because if
you take a long time all of those people
are gonna go into that queue before you
which means you will have to wait a lot
longer and then some countries some
airports they have forms that you have
to fill in as well and that's just going
to take a lot more time
stand at the right area of the carousel
you know that conveyor belt is going to
bring out the bags but then it's going
to go around you know and if you're
going to stand all the way the other end
you're just going to wait a long time
for the bags to reach you so
Pro tip just stand where the bags come
out
easy as that
keep your ticket close to you with the
sticker always always keep your ticket
close to you in your passport so that
you don't lose it with and this is
important with the sticker you know when
you check in your baggage they give you
a sticker with a few numbers on there
that prove that they have your bags a
lot of people think that they won't lose
their check in luggage but
you can and a lot of people do Nikita my
wife she lost her back and if we did not
have that sticker oh man we would have
been in trouble
extra security won't hurt
you know I come from South Africa and
stealing here for a lot of people
it's like they're addicted to it it's
like an epidemic here it's terrible lock
your back always before you check it in
most people only realize when they are
at home that something is missing and
then it's too late because then you
can't do anything about it you might
come from a safe country but you know
don't compare your country to other
countries because some people will steal
even if they work at airports you can
buy an extra lock like this one and even
a strap with a code lock like this one
and then lastly some airports like South
Africa they can even glad wrap your
whole bag for an extra fee of course all
right guys we're at the bonus tip thank
you guys for watching the video all the
way to the end thank you for the support
here it is
[Music]
take your own water bottle
for some reason when you get to airports
they just hike up the prices and you pay
an enormous amount just for water so
just take your own water bottle and then
you can fill it up they have these water
fountains and then it's free now if you
want to know the essentials things that
men should keep in their bedroom or car
watch these two videos here and I'll see
you there and before you go always
remember life is short so don't waste
yours cheers guys